okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the different types of radiation
so there's three different types we need
to know about which are alpha beta and
gamma we're going to learn the different
features about them and actually what is
each one so we're going to start with
alpha now the symbol for alpha is like
this now out of the three types of
radiation alpha travels the slowest
these alpha particles travel slower than
the other two now each of these types of
radiation can travel through different
things so alpha particles can travel
through the air but they can actually
get blocked by skin or in fact it can
even get blocked by paper so it's not
very penetrating it can be blocked by
paper so it's blocked by paper and as a
result its penetration is low so what is
an alpha particle so an alpha particle
is made up of two positive protons and
to neutral neutrons that means overall
it has a two plus charge and it's
exactly the same as a helium nucleus so
we see this is much bigger than the
other two it's made of two person two
neutrons and so travels up across quite
slowly now due to these things it's
actually quite ionizing it's highly
ionized
so strongly ionized in now what ionizing
means is the ability to turn an atom
into an ion and if this happens your DNA
this can cause mutations such as cancer
so we can see alpha is the most ionizing
so let's look at beta the symbol for
beta is this here now it's faster than
alpha it's faster than alpha however
it's not as fast as gamma like we'll see
in a minute now if we have a look at
this figure again we could see the beat
of this time go straight through paper
it goes straight through skin as well it
needs we need aluminium to block beta so
aluminium to block brighter as a result
it's moderate in turns its penetration
how deeply it goes into things now the
particle emitted now there's two
different types of beta radiation one is
this here beta with a little minus next
to it what that basically is is that
it's a fast-moving electron remember
electrons are much much smaller than a
proton or a neutron it's about 2,000 the
mass of a proton we can also get these
things here these beta plus which are
fast moving positron now a positron has
got the same mass as an electron so
again it's tiny but only it has a
positive charge so how iong is beta
radiation so the answer is moderately
moderately ionizing not as strong as
alpha in turning in at them into an ion
but moderately so now finally we need to
have a look at gamma so the symbol for
gamma is like this the speed of the gap
of gamma is the fastest now we should
hopefully know that gamma is part of the
electromagnetic spectrum so we know that
every single wave there it travels at
the speed loop speed of light so it's
much faster than the other two gamma
radiation travels at the speed of light
so let's have a look back against this
figure what actually blocks gamma so
gamma go straight through paper straight
through skin straight through aluminium
we actually need thick lead or concrete
in order to broad block it so therefore
its penetration is deep
so gamma actually isn't a particle at
all it's actually part of the
electromagnetic spectrum which means it
travels in waves so whereas the other
two remember this one's made of two
protons two neutrons and these are the
mass electron this doesn't have any mass
whatsoever it just travels as a wave how
ionizing is it
it's actually the least ionizing of the
three because it's more like to go
straight through something rather than
ionize it so as a result we can see all
of these now please notice that there's
usually there's a pattern each time so
the further we go down the table the
faster it faster the radiation is the
more penetrating it is but the lower the
ionization so guys that is basically the
difference between the different types
of radiation thank you